citizens of the reject Nation it is time for what
if season 2 episode 5 Coy how are we feeling oh
holy crap what if we make it we make it we
might do them all we might we might get to
Christmas ladies and gentlemen it's past
Christmas when this episode's coming out
so what you can do right now is tell us what
do you think about this episode is it a good
one does this satisfy your what if scenario bar
yet tell us what you hated about it be nitpicky
yeah that makes the internet happy argue with
someone just get the thumbs up on your opinion
down there in the comments by vitol leave a
like on this video ladies and gentlemen also
subscribe click the notification Bell because
we are powering through all of them and I've
been really enjoying the season th far thank
to all of you thanks is the word for joining
us at our patreon page full Reaction watch where
you seek up with your own copy of what if that's
available over there we cover several things with
highlights and watch alongs included but seriously
thank you all for helping us have a glorious
year at our patreon Co you ready I'm so ready
let's do it let's find out what this one's about
we don't see the titles in no idea what it is just
fine chatari I know I've seen this one I've seen
this movie Let's Come Oh Captain Carter's back
thanks G what are new friends for girls get
it done yeah ay Squad little trick I picked
up in Berlin uhhuh nice oh is this a sequel
I think it's seal to season 1's Carter where
did that move come from oh that you know Moscow
had a strange childhood Lake Bell is so good at
Black Widow just in general as a person too being
like Bell that was a violent Ant-Man wasp cool
oh good call th keep fighting down here Widow
let's go for a ride Hal well you so hot anytime
she's the captain of my heart her we could just
punch him a whole lot dos have a very punchable
face okay worried I'm a little worried guys
but we give a chance we're SL you into our
thought process while the opening credits are
going racial Vice from Black Widow I wonder
how that relate all right black widows in this
episode we'll see it's the most an opening has
worried me yeah the opening just had that what
of season one vibed it did and the further you
get away from what if season the better for
me like that's like an egregious season just
we don't talk about that one that's why we were
worried this whole time but now I'm enjoying it I
don't do sequels what's the point of revisiting
the story when there are infinite stories to
be told weird for the MCU to be telling me this
yeah about that revisiting she thought her story
was over but it was only just beginning so it's a
sequel to the last episode of what if season one
she's getting the win Soldier Story yes on your
left Fury has a mission for us man you need more
Hobbies it is the Winter Soldier it
literally is I can promise you that
this won't be the strangest thing I dealt
with today oh Steve oh he's going to be the
winner soldier the Hydra stomper Hydra stomp oh
yeah I guess he the antagonist there's someone
inside are I'm guessing going to
make him the villain cuz he's a white
man I'm Steve Rogers more
like RoboCop I'm the same
my you love uh oh what if Iron Giant was a bad
guy I do like that it's shot
like winter soldier sweet
sauce
maybe it's just that like resurrected
mind problem you know when you're like
who am I I have amnesia like Jason Bourne
yeah yeah I'll Attack I think it's going
to be the Winter Soldier Steve's hair he's
got beard oh he's got a beard he's Winter
Soldier they brainwashed
him you got to go to the market and get
plums
I do like the Winter Soldier outfit with the
Captain Britain flag on it Rogers and Barnes
formed their own two-man Army and destroyed every
Hydra base until the last mission claimed Steve's
life rumors about the hydro stomper survival
since the 1960s why wasn't I debriefed on this
because we didn't debrief you on Bigfoot
either if the stories are true then the
hydro stomper is responsible for some of the
world's worst acts of Terror rewind back what
about Bigfoot yeah is he real like bucking
it was rumored that her old home found and
housed the Hydra stomper Rachel we uh Steve
evil you didn't tell me didn't see the point
in breaking your heart twice okay so season
one was a lot of what if we remake a movie as
an episode this is worrying this is where we
smash things together the stomper the world's
most dangerous killer I have a shield a shield
ain't going to stop it I mean she's got super
strength surely you understand that the sovian
aid package is generous considering considering
it doesn't cover has Barnes you got a age oh
that's cool won't have a country torn apart by
Civil War because we didn't do the right thing
that's greaty would sir we believe there might
be an attempt on your life I may be an old man
boys but I've punched Nazis and shed beers with
aliens someone read my catheter get down get
down oh that's cool mirroring the end see I feel
like that Shield would do would do damage I mean
it saved like 30 people just now that thing is an
international terrorist attempting to assassinate
a Us official trusting you to do the right thing
this feels more like Nick Fury than he doesn't the
Marvel's or secret Invasion the second half secret
evasion thieves in the suits alive well that's a
different Kell ofon something Howard cooked
up after the war good that means I can break
it it is interesting because it's a love
story you know and she wants to save him
yeah but so so was Bucky and Steve yeah
but that's more like we best butts this
this is good I'm having fun with this one
I think it's better than the first episode
of season one yeah and I think it's an
inventive way to make Winter Soldier
work again it's hard because it just feels
like hitting the same story beats cuz it
is we'll see well sick I'm giving it a shot
coin
it's fun seeing Evil Steve I'm sad to
see himam go down I'm hoping he's like
Nomad a come on cool locked in on the target
weapons High we do permission to shoot n what
secretary no Steve would be stupid enough to
do the same for me Steve hey oh my God kill him
Steve this should be great old man Bucky this
ain't you let's get a drink kill him like the
old days what do you say buddy kill him you and me
oh I think they might actually that closeup makes
me think they're going to kill him okay I was
wrong nope it's fake out there it go oh we got
both that's a great cool honestly a lot
of the animation action Sav so much much
better and again Winter Soldier badass
brutal hand to hand the bar was high
oh the reverse of through the walls is
through the ceiling oh yeah yeah I like
that it actually feels like someone drew this time
yes versus a computer made it all AI is bad Marvel
lesson learned I'm glad they got their AI to
make it look hand yeah better AI save him do
the thing to die faster put your hands behind
your back it works with science it's real St
Steve wake up oh no hey Peg I got you catch him
as opposed to jumping out of the plane catch him
with a plane why don't you just reverse the plane
tap the brakes reverse the play Slow the plane
down we're in come on come on come on come on come
on come on Good Luck Carter thank
you sucker for a good love story
huh welcome to St Kilda
Scotland why' you spill the
beans fo's here I got the reference why just
F your beans the only thing keeping him alive
you can't remove it n unless you want to put him
straight into a coffin you got to go to someone
from the Red Room his suit's rebooting now we'll
see who's at the controls when he wakes up I do
like that it's obviously still skinny Steve but
they're making the gauntness tie into the machine
keeping him alive what if we no well if not Stark
then Banner no unplugging it and plugging it back
in is not going to work did you try that tends to
work we'll go to the Red Room what I've never been
a woman to quit a fight the Red Room did this
Rachel W before I join Shield tracking down and
killing the head of the Red Room are you certain
you killed him mhm dabbed him in the coted artery
with a cork screw so yeah I think I did but
at the end of the day it meant nothing I like
the pairing of them a lot really fun yeah no one
can find it not even Shield sorry I can take you
also cap this a similar relationship of hierarchy
it's been a while Peggy I owe you that date Steve
should have said dance not too far from the Red
Room a sovian military base training camp for KGB
spies when the Kremlin abandoned it the Red Room
moved in it started off Rocky but I'm enjoying
it man we see I'm I'm half in I'm pretty in I'm
more in than not that's not fair I'm like 70% in
I'm just hoping it lands with enough Hood Spa to
rationalize the First Act being Winter Soldier
again a great day in the neighborhood but I'm INRI
oh this is cool it's like an those nuclear towns
those testing sites yeah which is where you'd
want to build a plutonium man I love America I
feel like I'm in a horror movie I we wants fought
a giant space squid I signal the Red Room it's
bait it turned pretty easy
okay uh I'm going to go find
a lemonade stand or something
he just he a dink against his
metal it's the real Iron stomper what do
you think of the future in a word faster
cars computers even the news moves fast and
uh the men do they move faster oh yeah a it's
a baby so creepy I spent years going after
Hydra as long as I was on a mission I could
pretend you weren't G it's crazy no not crazy
very human M finally Peggy widow bites packs
sting o oh creepy it's a baby cool cool cool
cool I'm so down yes the Red Room using this
propaganda oh that's rad pile
through this looks
incredible Sho there wow wow
you for got to mention these
robots aren't very nice sorry
my memory is a little fuzzy it's like Iron Man 2o
yeah Russia thought America was like this we
didn't get cable TV over here just shows up
without a shield let me just show up go this is
what would happen pretty Qui what you think Black
Widow whoa that is unsettling it's
unnerving cuz it has that ironic
family touch that americ the Red Room oh I'm sorry
Natasha but we turned your bedroom into a
gam oh she in charge there she is mission
accomplished ma'am no regret no boss only me and
his mission there might have been some truth to
their connection all right you can say I told
you so later I don't want to fight in front of
my mom mom is let's unpack that later shall we
this was all a trap to find me okay now I might
say it I don't know whether to kiss you kill
you or dissect you maybe all three yes good
plan all my widows have seen your movie that was
a movie it was a musical Ah that's clever Easter
egg oh let's see it o is she going to be I
mean the the shoes have been something get
her damn it
Steve I got my two pistols there's no
problem that's plenty it's fine I can
roll
booyaah some great tracking shots man DP work
combining Winter Soldier and black
widow like this I'm in it's got me
it works works really well cool reverse
Avenger shot Dave this isn't you wake
up oh that's fun I like that
use wow so sick the action in this is so good how
could Natasha have survived this I think she got
clear it's me Steve it's Peggy you owe me a
date mess with his head psychological mind
Warfare not the cookies everyone
needs those especially Santa
cool yeah I like the Sinister plays a lot
here there you go you're working the Shadows
crunchie yeah beat his brain
back she cool oh excellent that was excellent
dope damn oh that was a top ped oh wow
this is a beautiful sequence this Haun
so stunning hard aim for her left knee she damaged
in bicycle accident in third grade
this [__] I love how just a training
session all right let's see her power set
ooh starting to feel like Batman
the Animated Series yeah it's
like the the visual expression of The Haunting
Flames great I can't get over how much better it
looks and how the action feels so much
more weighted I am done fighting Steve
I've been fighting for so long to end
the war I'd like to see some like marks
on her though even if this is the end
I want you but he can't get out of the
suit oh no no no yeah man
you just got back wait no no
a ouch Batman
yep there it goes that where that
I was like where' that handle
go o wow some serious
composition oh wow that was
a pretty shot Matt Matt are
you all right no we need to run of course we
do start off worried man but I really like this
the First Act I was not I was really worried it'd
be a rehashing and instead they comined this isn't
the end of her story whenever they go past just
the sounds silly the what the what if part yeah
and they just embrace the story they're telling
it it always turns out great this season I see
all I observe all I know what the hell is this
hey Natasha oh the interconnected one a good
question yep we're teasing the interconnected
episode will more than likely get right in the
finale I'm assuming show us strange Supreme is
it strange Supreme that is she what 1602 more
she will s our world so much for taking a night
off watch you watch you 1602 is going to be
awesome if the big finale 1602 I'm going to
lose my [__] might just be the next that was
awesome a that was cool you know what's really
cool though what's cool that shirt you're
wearing Coy yeah it is it's a great way to
show you're a real reject supporter a real one
a real real reject supporter and also like we
got the space babies of the Galaxy one we've
got who influences the influencers we've got
Child Protection Services we got a whole bunch
of te's and it is absolutely my personal favorite
way just saying to support the channel and you
look good while doing it I mean come on you know
those are comfortable and they F Well very comfy
breathes well it's got some fluidity to it and it
looks great bounce the pecs hold on there you
go yeah look Hydra get get closer little Frank
gorillo action little Crossbones for you now
we're going to get flagged for inappropriate
content because of because of my pegy Carters
nice pecky Carters you did it you did it I need
water we've been doing this for hours I really
haven't drank any water today I'm like must be
what I'm I need water um yeah uh okay okay
I'm there with you concern top opening Pro
I was like oh God this feels like like all the
problems of what if season one just like cheesy
Fest and like hey what if we just swapped out some
people and then it's not like a what if it's like
a let's just remake it yes and I was I had the
same concern as you you got ahead of it a little
faster than me you you you were more in about five
minutes before me and then I hit a point where I
was like oh no he's right because it I started to
see the the through line of where they were going
with it of like oh we're going to combine elements
of the Black Widow storyline and the and the and
the captain Carter storyline but you know the
thing is with with all these episodes of what if
every single one of them feels like they could use
an extra five to 10 minutes I agree they should
not have done this tight 30 they would have all
benefited by like a nice 35 especially our Le I
think both of us agree episode two is the weakest
um because For Me episode two lands the softest
this landed really well this landed great like
it got better as it kept going and the weight
of the fight scenes in particular are fantastic I
love the setting I just love how much emotion can
be evoked solely due to what they're drawing you
know and like the to throw them into the ironic
haunting setting of the nuclear test site which
has imagery that evokes where the the time period
they they actually originate from I think is great
how and how that ties into Red Room it ties into
both the movies it's like that perfect ven diagram
of the Russian propaganda and the Americana yes
yeah like the the horrors of their past converging
aesthetically not just character-wise but and and
and how they told like really you know they
they make all the comments all the time about
like Bucky and Steve is really a love story and
they actually just told the Love Story version
here which I thought was excellent uh I don't
feel personally like I liked this Agent Carter
I thought as an episode it's a really great like
it got to a great point and like again so much
of the time unlike season 1 so much of the time
there can be moments that I think are absolutely
undoubtedly saved by just wow look how great this
actually looks 100% you guys got to keep in mind
too we are fortunate enough to be watching this
on a screener um you know because uh we're part
of the press list for him and we're fortunate to
watching the screener and that is not as great a
quality yeah we're watching this downgraded yeah
yeah as what you guys get to watch or watching on
like Disney plus servers or something and and I'm
still like this looks amazing also you may notice
how bright it is in here we're watching this
under fluoresence like if you're watching this in
the dark in high quality it must look even better
because right now we're like a little blinded and
watching it like on a you know screener so this is
this Show's gorgeous yeah it's absolutely gorgeous
and and I and so much of that and again when
you're doing animation more than a a liveaction
with CGI or whatever animation has to has to
elicit an emotion it has to it just has to and
I think this show is actually doing it yeah and so
I could watch these moments of fight scenes that
are just not just like oh look how cool and pretty
that is it has weight it has character it it moves
the story it a lot of times with like a liveaction
movie you might be like oh I need to watch like
the I need to be invest in the characters in order
to care about the visuals the visuals can get
you emotionally invested that's what I'm talking
about with the inverse here agree and I think that
is the strength of what if season 2 in particular
now has any episode so far risen to the heights of
this doctor strange episode not for me personally
in terms of a story I think as a consistency
though and as an overall season it a far out does
season one already yeah there's no finale feel I
mean obviously we're not to the finale yet but
there's nothing that feels as strong as episode
8 season 1 I agree but four was four right or
four five the strange Supreme one oh and then
it wrapped up in eight yeah yeah yeah talking
about four I'm talking about the just the doctor
strange episode yeah like that was like a perfect
like 30 minute episode yeah it was it was pretty
incredible but but for me this is Leaps and Bounds
above the average feel oh yeah yeah like that I
would rather have the problem with season one is
that's one phenomenal episode out of like eight
fine like seven of them are like fine and here
I'm like no there's there's a lot of greatness
and almost I don't remember much about two but
but one three four like there's there's been
pretty much something great yeah in every single
one of them and it's so funny cuz 88 was the one I
was looking forward to most that was like that
like premise wise but I think that also shows
how good the episodes have been that the premise
hasn't been what's got me it's been the delivery
on the premise as it's presented yeah exactly cuz
this one like you said the premise I was like I'm
a little concerned and then as soon as it like
actually let me breathe I was like man this is
stunning I'm invested I love the convergence of
themes and ideas and the delivery is incredible
my my only concern is I still and I want to
I still don't feel as much for Agent Carter
exactly Captain Carter is I want to because if you
like have you have you interviewed or met um Haley
Atwell no no I second you do melt everything
Cap's ever done makes sense like if you're
in the the same breathing space as Haley Atwell
suddenly you're like I would fight for 100 years
and go back in time and and abandon everything
I would absolutely kill off Rebecca Ferguson to
have Haley ell and convert her to Scientology as
needed you do what you got to do do what you got
to do to keep her and that is what I don't feel
from the animated version and that's unfortunate
that's the only thing I wish I could like connect
to yeah you know and in what I'm I'm gonna bring
it back to your point in a second because what's
what was missing for me here when I said I wish
there were some marks on Peggy what after she
was fighting with Steve when she's saying I'm
tired I'm like okay yeah you're you're saying
you're tired we need to see it you know when in
Winter Soldier when he's fighting with Bucky at
the end and and he's just I could do this all day
whatever and he's he's refusing to like give up
on Bucky yeah he's he's Captain America but he's
still looks like messed up yeah and if they did
that with Peggy then that would have just hit so
much harder and it's her accent on top of it that
Feels So Posh and Polished it's like she's fine
all the time like there's also that verbal element
of like yeah you're good it seems like yeah you're
you're quitting because you're emotionally tired
but I feel like you can also be visually tired
yeah like we need need to like physically mess
you up a little I want to care about Captain
Carter I do yeah cuz I like the chemistry between
her and black widow and I I I think this show is
absolutely at its best whenever they get past
winking at the audience and that's what I mean
by when they get past SE and Jeff Goblin Winks at
a self with but like they could have easily done
with like uh with Rachel vice's character Melania
Melina Melinda Melinda something like that Melania
Trump Melania yeah yeah um check her grave oh no
that's the other one his other wife they could
have just been like oh she's look at us we're
what if and she's the villain no they just they
just they just do it she's just a villain yeah and
I think whenever they get past winking is when the
show is excelling cuz in a universe you wouldn't
know the other viers to wink so when they do it it
like takes you out of the suspension of disbelief
of like wait wait we're in another universe that's
not special here it's just the way things are
so when they make it special I'm like you guys
don't get the premise and season one did a lot of
winking it was alln it was nothing but like except
swapped it four and eight weren't winging and
that's why we're were referring to them as as the
good ones especially four if I if I rewatch what
if in a year or two or if I ever do a a massive
Marvel rewatch I'll probably watch episodes four
eight and then this as my what if yeah no I I
don't I I've never rewatched I've only rewatched
the doctor Str that's I watch the finale because
I do assume that'll tie in to Secret Wars in some
way but that's it yeah yeah 48 this cuz this has
all been great and rewatchable and Christmas is
now got I think this has been awesome this has
really been awesome overall and even like yeah I
I I think a lot of this was really uh I can't wait
to see I yeah I'm curious how it lands at at their
ninth episode can't wait to see can't wait to see
more all right koyi let's see more let's see more
by ending this video first let's do that and I'm
going to get some water you should you seem
you you you you look vexed you look how Peggy
Carter should after figh tired you look a little
disoriented I was like I'm Tire I'm usually tired
but I'm more tired than usual dehydrated and
I'm like oh yeah I'm probably really dehydrate
his eyes are wavering yeah all right guys
let's go to the bathroom everybody go to the
bathroom